do you guys ever worry that like you
know what the songwriting process was so
beautiful when we lived in that house
together that no way we should almost
just go home
and try to capture that again or is
there no going back there's really no
i don't think there's going back to that
house and i think that maybe i had that
worry like when phineas moved out
but
as soon as we started because he he
built a studio in his basement so it's
still a home studio right um
and we made it nice i have like nice
windows and my
nice windows nice windows
it's very plain like the things that i
liked very rick rubin
pretty much over my like stage voice
because i used to be like yeah what's up
yeah just don't know i had this like
voice that i would do in phineas phineas
hasn't gotten there yet i'm trying my
best he's still doing his i'm cool voice
i'm trying so hard
well wait a second
so so phineas your
career
yes it has gotten so big in the sense
that now everybody and his [ __ ]
mother wants you to produce their album
we've all seen the documentary that you
guys put out and and very much so like
in the process i went holy [ __ ]
phineas is a madman with not only music
but computers and sound effects and if i
was a musician i'd want you to produce
my record
now if i'm billy um but if i'm billy i'm
sitting there going [ __ ] this
why do i need this guy's attention on
other people and giving good ideas to
other people
billy tell us now how angry and upset
you are with all of this be honest i
mean
don't you want him to yourself in a
sense
i i do but i also trust him and i know
that he's not i mean i think but i feel
that i know uh pretty well that he's not
gonna go make my music with other people
because it's it's
you because you better not i would argue
i would argue that i can't go make her
music with other people because she's
her music do you know what i mean like
i'm i'm involved in two of us but it's
the billy
but yes it is you know phineas is like
oh i was with stones the other day and
we were writing songs and i'm like [ __ ]
that bye
exactly billy billy takes precedent over
all that like i would never like billy's
first always